solche waghalsigen kampfszenen machen
einen bond film zum traum einer jeden
stuntfrau
[Musik]
dass ich das noch mal mitnehmen durfte
als
hauptdarstellerin und acht monate diesen
film gedreht habe war eine ganz ganz
tolle erfahrung die berlinerin maria
umjubelt die britische schauspielerin
der scheune lynch die erste schwarze
doppelnull agentin im 25 bond-abenteuer
keine zeit zu starten dieser james bond
film beweist dass frauen eben genauso
action-helden denken
action szenen wie diese zählen zu den
stoff aus dem filme gemacht sind die
deutsche marine ruby sieg den feind auf
der großen leinwand als land google für
hollywoods größten
aktuell dreht marie mehrere monate einen
film in new york wieder ein
actionreiches abenteuer der weg bis zum
heutigen erfolg war kein leichter als
schwarze frau geboren und aufgewachsen
ist die 29 jährige in berlin
berlin in berlin friedrichshain groß
geworden sind zu einer zeit wo es schon
relativ gefährlich war für uns schwarze
kinder auf der straße sag ich mal und
wir auf situationen hatten
die bisschen gefährlicher waren und so
beginnt die kleine marie mit dem
kampfsport training
mit 14 gewinnt sie zum ersten mal
internationale wettbewerbe um sich für
die anspruchsvollen einsätze fit zu
halten muss sie täglich trainieren für
den job als dann frau braucht man zwar
keine lizenz aber eine starke kondition
dafür zahlt sie einen hohen preis
bei der arbeit als landfrau ist es
natürlich auch nicht unüblich dass man
sich verletzen kann die
verletzungsgefahr ist auch groß auch
wenn sie nicht sein sollte viele sachen
sind super geplant und trotzdem kann man
sich verletzen lassen sollte man sich
bewusst sein also ich hab mich schon
öfter kleinere verletzungen zufügen aber
ich habe auch schon etwas größere
verletzungen habe mir mal den
mindestkurs angegriffen oder
fuß gebrochen und solche sachen aber die
heilen dann und dann geht's weiter
marion start in der filmindustrie war
nicht leicht lange zeit waren
action-helden ausschließlich männlich
und weiß und die meisten stunts selbst
für weibliche rollen wurden von männern
übernommen
so schwer für mich jobs zu kriegen als
frau und danach als schwarze frau ist
also doppelt blöd eigentlich in dem
moment an war ich auch anderen punkt wo
ich auch verzweifelt war nach der 1 ich
weiß nicht wie das weitergeht ob das für
mich auch überhaupt nicht zukunft hat
ihren durchbruch erlebt sie 2018 als
jubel in einem hollywood action
blockbuster seit black panther ist es
weltweit hat sich das filmbild verändert
weltweit auf einmal als in jedem film
auf jeden fall schwarze leute
repräsentiert viele starke schwarze
rollen für all diese rollen steht marin
ruhm als stuntfrau bereit
momentan ist es so dass ich extrem stolz
auf mich selbst bin auch manchmal echt
mich so erwischt wie ich gar nicht
fassen kann was ich gerade bin leben
führe also genau das was ich mir die
beiden jahre aufgebaut hat was ich mir
immer gewünscht habe und zugleich ebnet
sie den weg für weitere frauen die ihren
beispiel nun folgen können